what's up reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we're
gonna watch not Thor love and thunder
trailer that's the one everyone's
looking forward to the jojo rabbit
trailer let's go check this out Tyco
whitey tees the latest film barely know
anything about it I heard a rumor he
plays Hitler that's about it
[Music]
[Music]
business
[Music]
there are
hey Jojo my old friend hiya Dolph oh man
they call me a scared rabbit they can
say whatever they want
people used to say a lot of nasty things
about me oh this guy's a lunatic oh look
at that psycho he's gonna get us all
killed
[Music]
what the hell well that was weird psycho
ITT and should be weird got that offbeat
quirky sensibility yeah that's the
that's the way he does this will
definitely be met with some controversy
if you don't understand satire any way
shape or form I would imagine but this
communicates is pretty broad and pretty
silly to me unless you love Hitler I
can't imagine you'll be two of them I
feel like it'd all be met with some
controversy especially just a teiko by
TT portray Hitler to this degree
I'm not upset watching it I don't feel
like there's anything controversial
necessarily represented here you know
how the internet tends to be and
sometimes the subject matter is just
that sensitive for people how dare they
not cast a German to play Hitler I know
right so the the plot described here is
a young boy Hitler's army finds out his
mother is hiding a Jewish girl in their
home the boys obviously German
yeah and from what I understand he wants
to be a part of Hitler's ranks yeah he's
very much into the Nazi thing and his
mother is Scarlett Johansson I'm
assuming and they are hiding a Jewish
girl see that it's like a very real plot
like that's a real thing I feel like
making a comedy out of that kidding you
can that's where I feel like people can
get it like yeah oh really
to treat this with a comedic approach to
it you know yeah I mean from what I've
heard him say about it I feel like the
hearts gonna be in the right place cuz
he keeps describing this as an anti hate
satire with that in mind that perfectly
reads to me from this trailer but yeah I
can definitely see it as some people
being like oh this is nothing that
should ever be trivialized and that's
the tricky thing about satires that you
know it's not always trivial it's just
that the use of humor may be too much
for some people I think it'll be fine I
think you know I mean the cast is
amazing here it's still weird seeing
Taika Waititi
yeah and it's such as like you know
affable friendly way yeah like bringing
a little bit of that coorg or that you
know what we do in the shadows to it is
is I go YTD doing doing it yeah
exactly that yeah you know the idea the
cast does sound excited to have in here
I mean it was just like quick glimpses
is a woman at ease I feel like there's
an official trailer should be coming out
pretty soon seeing the star-studded cast
you got Sam Rockwell in here you got
Scarlett Johansson in here rebel Wilson
and Stephen Merchant - and especially
for rebel Wilson I'm kind of excited to
see her hopefully maybe do a different
kind of comedic role under the direction
of somebody like Tycho itt's no man she
has to be overweight that's yeah they're
the only thing secure that's the only
joke yes overweight uh ha that's funny
yeah that's funny
overweight funny you know we got to get
as her and Melissa McCarthy in a comedy
where they team up to be overweight and
bumbling trapped and nothing else - room
eating hamburgers yeah and just
ad-libbing the entire just gained more
weight over the course of yeah minute
and then we're all like how funny is it
this air they're there you know any
plus-sized women to be fair funny Aarthi
does a little bit more branching out
yeah she has she has yeah yeah leave her
out of the conversation yes
well hey you know rebels got cats coming
up John we don't want to make fun of
overweight people who make fun of
themselves consistently for being
overweight yeah so back to this movie it
kind of has a bit I don't know if this
is just because of the whole Boy Scout
thing moonrise kingdom
moonrise kingdom or or even within the
taiko itz catalog you've got hunt for
the will Drupal yeah as a Scout angle on
it who does seem to have a little bit of
Wes Anderson meets Tycho YTV kind of
vibe there's something I feel like that
comes up in his work a decent amount or
at least his personal work and maybe I'm
just going off a couple movies but you
know about like boy door and coming of
age and father figures and things like
that because also from what I understand
here I don't know if Hitler will make up
an appearance assume we probably would
as the actual Hitler but from what I
understand in this trailer at least this
is his sort of imaginary friend version
of him who he looks up to and like a
father figure sorts yeah I think that's
fine you know but if real Hitler shows
up that's when they got a double
on the comedy no totally yeah they gotta
make any committees malaria's just make
him like slip on banana peels at every
term just saying imaginary Hitler
that's funny idea whatever real Hitler
now that's where a comedy gold of that
that's right like World War Two was so
funny so funny whole time
literally the other night who's Saturday
night and I was like let's just unwind
babe put on Schindler's List oh yeah
grab our copy of Mein Kampf I
specifically did an editing project and
color corrected the whole thing oh good
yeah yeah it's so fun like and white
it's pretty dramatic but in color oh my
god oh boy oh boy what a great yeah what
a C vivid a storytelling after
everything I said at the beginning of
this video this is a great idea you have
found the funny that I have seen forever
alright guys are you excited for Jojo
number nine and leave a comment down
below you can subscribe for the real
rejects please click that notification
belt show us some love by giving us some
love and before we wrap this up peach
from the day shout-out to a man named
Jake Stewart chase do so that's your
shadow a couple months ago he was
messaging me saying that he had a new
girlfriend now it's been a few months of
dating her new girlfriend and he is a
she'd never seen the MCU film so he was
watching the whole thing with her
binging it and then I haven't heard back
from him and awhile like literally two
months ago I replied to him me to reply
to me last week and he says sorry for
the radio silence start a new job and
didn't realize my payment went through
and reset I think he's only still here
because he forgot to take his card off
file and now I feels bad cuz he saw your
messages and he's like I got to do at
least a month well I appreciate that if
all of our patrons can stay pledged out
of guilt I'm okay with that you know so
Jake if you're the top contender for
like guilt leader please hold the mantle
you're doing a great job buddy I hope
you're a girlfriend and
the MCU films and I hope she likes
Hitler